popular Las Vegas Brewery is getting
ready to close its doors after serving
tourists and locals for more than two
decades as Victoria Saha explains Gordon
Biersch right over near Paradise and
Flamingo about a prime location as it
was a hot spot for many
after more than two decades the patrons
here at Gordon Biersch will say cheers
they're sweet I have a hole in my heart
right now for 27 years Gordon Biersch
has been the go-to place for many of
their customers some taking a break from
the strip are those like Frederick
Brooks who often stops by after a long
day of work you're having a bad day when
you come in here when you leave you're
not going to have a bad day knowing
their cold beer would be the right fix
for him
where am I going to take it
I'm gonna keep it until I find another
place because his days of getting a
generous Pour at the brewery are
numbered I'm coming tomorrow
until it closes I'm bringing my growl in
and let it fill it up so I won't go dry
One Last Time One Last Time CEO Josh
Curran says they did everything to make
their new lease work but the numbers
were just too high so when it's sad
um it certainly is kind of you know has
that heavy feeling of you know we've got
a you know close something that you know
has been part of many people's lives
lives like Ralph melonson who has been a
regular since their doors first opened
and the food and the beer is phenomenal
here we've always loved it and he will
be there when their doors close it's
gonna be sad it'll be some tears in my
beer until then Victoria eight news now
Victoria thank you the brewery will
close at 10 pm on Sunday really a staple
in town I was just telling you part of
my job interview was there at the end of
my channel a job interview I had lunch
there to the station it was we all went
there often